en este vídeo vamos a determinar el
volumen de otro sólido y si nos da
tiempo también vamos a determinar el
área de su superficie el sólido que nos
interesa en esta ocasión es el cilindro
así que déjame pintar por aquí déjame
pintar por aquí la tapa del cilindro que
es un círculo visto en perspectiva
aquí los lados del cilindro ahí tenemos
un lado vale y aquí abajo voy a poner la
base que también es un círculo igualito
al de acá arriba del mismo radio aquí
pues está la parte de atrás no se ve
bueno podemos pensar que es transparente
y que se ve así como un poco menos
fuerte vale entonces ahí tenemos un
cilindro puedes imaginarte digamos una
lata de refresco bueno queremos
determinar el volumen de este cilindro
sabiendo que su altura que su altura h
es ocho centímetros h es igual a ocho
centímetros y que el radio de las bases
bueno de la tapa y de la base es de 4
centímetros deja lo pongo con otro color
entonces sabemos que este radio r
r lo voy a poner así r es igual a 4
centímetros muy bien entonces cómo le
hacemos para determinar el volumen de
este cilindro pues como le hemos hecho
con los otros sólidos que hemos
encontrado lo que tenemos que hacer es
determinar el área de esta tapa el área
de esta etapa de acá eso nos va a dar
algo en centímetros cuadrados y luego al
multiplicar por estos ocho centímetros
de la altura vamos a recorrer todo el
cilindro y eso nos va a dar el volumen
entonces déjame empezar con esta etapa
que es un círculo lo voy a pintar acá
entonces tenemos un círculo y sabemos
que ese círculo tiene radio cuatro radio
cuatro y por lo tanto el área vamos a
ponerle así el área de la base de esta
base circular pues es el área de este
círculo de radio 4 y para eso
simplemente necesitamos multiplicar pi
por el radio que es 4 centímetros 4
centímetros y elevarlo al cuadrado
cuánto nos da esto pues esto es 4
perdón espín y por 4 al cuadrado que es
16 por centímetros al cuadrado por
centímetros al cuadrado déjame
escribirlo un poco más bonito como 16 x
pi por centímetros por centímetros al
cuadrado al cuadrado muy bien entonces
esto de aquí ya es un área ahora para
determinar el volumen del cilindro
tenemos que multiplicar esa área por
ocho centímetros entonces déjame ponerlo
por acá el volumen el volumen del
cilindro va a ser igual a esta área que
estoy poniendo en color como rosa que es
16 16 por pi por centímetros cuadrados
multiplicado por esta altura de acá x 8
centímetros por 8 centímetros
aquí podemos reacomodar los números
utilizando la propiedad conmutativa de
la multiplicación entonces obtenemos que
esto es igual a 16 por 8 16 por 4 64 por
12 128 entonces nos queda 128
por centímetros al cuadrado por
centímetros que es centímetros cúbicos
entonces el volumen es igual a 128 pi
por centímetros cúbicos
recuerda que pi simplemente es un número
pero no lo escribimos porque es
irracional y está súper loco entonces
pues no no podríamos escribir todo pi
pero podríamos aproximar esta expresión
utilizando una calculadora como pies
3.14 pues esto va a ser bueno va a estar
cercano a 400 centímetros cúbicos vale
bueno entonces con esto determinamos el
volumen ahora como le haríamos para
determinar el área de la superficie de
este cilindro bueno pues hay varias
áreas que tenemos que considerar una es
el área de esta etapa una es el área de
esta base que es igual al área de la
tapa y finalmente está como la cosa que
envuelve al cilindro vale entonces
tenemos que separar el área de la
superficie en esas tres áreas déjame
pintar también con este mismo color rojo
esta área de acá porque es igual a la de
arriba vale entonces esta es igual a
esta de modo que el área de la
superficie déjame escribirlo aquí el
área de la superficie no voy a poner de
este lado
a área de la superficie
pues para empezar debe de tener estas
dos áreas y entonces debe de ser igual a
2 por esto que ya determinamos 16 por pi
centímetros cuadrados centímetros
cuadrados ya eso tenemos que sumar el
área de la cosa que envuelve al cilindro
y cómo le hacemos para determinar el
área de esa cosa que envuelve al
cilindro pues pensemos que si es una
envoltura de adeveras que es una
envoltura de papel y lo que vamos a
hacer es cortar esa envoltura entonces
vamos a vamos a cortar esta envoltura
por aquí vale y vamos a desdoblar la
entonces ésta la vamos a desdoblar para
acá y esta para acá y mira aquí tenemos
ángulos rectos
aquí tenemos ángulos rectos de modo que
al desdoblar la envoltura vamos a
obtener un rectángulo que voy a pintar
en perspectiva así
vemos este rectángulo
y algo de este estilo más o menos
rectángulo aquí es recto aquí es recto
aquí es recto y aquí es recto entonces
justo aquí donde cortamos que voy a
poner cuando un naranja un poco más
fuerte corresponde a este lado y a este
lado de esta forma conocemos la altura
de este rectángulo la altura es de 8
centímetros de ocho centímetros va y
ahora lo que necesitamos conocer es su
base pero esta base de donde viene pues
esta base esta base de acá
justo viene de esta orilla verdad de
esta orilla que estoy marcando entonces
la base del rectángulo una vez que lo
desdoblamos la base de la envoltura
coincide con el perímetro del círculo de
abajo y lo mismo sucede arriba verdad
también coincide con este perímetro de
acá cuando ahí me quedé un poco chueco
pero se ve la idea entonces para
determinar esta base simplemente debemos
determinar el perímetro del círculo de
aquí abajo entonces déjame ponerle p
para determinar el perímetro de este
círculo sabemos que su radio es 4 la
fórmula del perímetro es 2 por pi por el
radio entonces el perímetro nos quedaría
igual a 22 centímetros por bueno no 2
centímetros todavía no 2 por pi y ahora
si vienen los centímetros por el radio
que es 4 centímetros 4 centímetros ok
entonces nos queda 2 x 4 que es 8 8 y 8
centímetros ocho centímetros entonces la
base de este rectángulo es 8 centímetros
y eso está súper padre porque con ella
con la base y con la altura podemos
determinar el área el área de este
rectángulo y por lo tanto podemos
determinar el área de la de la envoltura
qué es lo que nos faltaba ya nada más
determinamos eso por acá déjame ponerlo
en color blanquito entonces el área le
voy a poner si el área de la envoltura
es igual a 8 centímetros
por 8 centímetros que es igual a 64
centímetros cuadrados muy bien esto está
súper padre entonces aquí tenemos que
sumar el área de la envoltura que es 64
centímetros al cuadrado y aquí podemos
simplificar para ver qué nos queda esto
de aquí es igual a 32 por pi centímetros
cuadrados más 64 centímetros cuadrados
esto es igual a 96 centímetros cuadrados
centímetros cuadrados y por lo tanto el
área de la superficie de nuestro
cilindro es igual a 96 centímetros
cuadrados
efe este ejercicio sí que estuvo súper
largo y observa tiene sentido que aquí
hayamos obtenido centímetros cuadrados
porque esto es un área el área tiene que
ver con cuántos cuadraditos con cuántos
cuadraditos podemos poner sobre la
superficie cuántos cuadraditos de uno
por uno vale entonces por eso son
centímetros cuadrados y el volumen que
está aquí arriba 128 centímetros cúbicos
pues tiene unidades cúbicas porque el
volumen se refiere a cuántos cubitos
de uno por uno por uno podemos meter en
el interior del cilindro bueno
aproximadamente vale bueno espero que te
haya gustado este problema nos vemos en
siguientes vídeos